so now we're we'll move into the ideas
of Egyptian uh biogeometry the knowledge
of what was done in the ancient Egyptian
temples was basically lost and they have
a saying in Egypt that our Mysteries
were never betrayed meaning that what
was secret in the temple stayed secret
in the temple you know for myself and
for many other people who begin to
remember past lives one of the first
past lives they remember is Egyptian now
I find that fascinating because we've
had other past lives more recently why
don't we remember those first there's
something about the Egyptian
incarnations that are so significant to
us would the energetic
frequency that we lived in that life be
so loud as maybe the like of just a
slang word but so such a high frequency
such a standout frequency that we're
picking up at that energetic signature
in our past first because it's like the
most complicated did the most
Progressive could it be that I do think
that's one part of it many of the images
you see in classical religions are
sacred geometry forms that have a deeper
meaning or teaching behind them but only
the initiates are taught the deeper
meaning the average person only
understands a surface level example the
original Jewish menorah from the Jewish
kabbalistic tradition so there's seven
candlesticks the first one is connected
in a great Arc to the seventh one the
second in a great Arc to the sixth the
third in a great Arc to the fifth and
the fourth one stands alone now the
Jewish capitalistic tradition has a very
deep understanding of Time and Time
cycles and so what this embeds is that
certain periods of time are divided into
seven stages like a seven stage
alchemical process and time cutting to
the chase you're going into all the
details in the time since the Atlantean
catastrophe and the Western tradition
misunderstood for example with the
European resecrutions that the third
post-atlancian Epoch was the Egyptian
eat puck
and the one we're at now is the fifth
Epoch the European Epoch where the
Europeans became the dominant people
that's what we're in now that's right
and so there's a connection between the
third and the fifth because it's like
the fourth is the dividing point it's
like a mirror image so the third and the
fifth are mirrors of each other second
and the sixth first and the seventh
without going into all the other details
of it this means that we're in a part of
a Time cycle right now where if you
understand the greater structure of the
time cycle is we're having a certain
type of reflection going the opposite
direction of what we had in ancient
Egypt and so we have a natural
fascination with our time in ancient
Egypt and if you turn on you know some
documentary channel on TV the vast
majority of documentaries about ancient
cultures are all about Egypt there's
very very few about ancient Persia and
other cultures they're all about Egypt
but that's because that's being
reawakened in us the knowledge we had
then but now in a later stage of
evolution so there's all of there's
hidden sacred geometry patterns of time
as well as in space
so that's my answer to the whole thing
about you know why is the Egyptian so
important now
how is it that we're connecting to these
different
time space react time space realities
the third and the fifth the first and
the seventh these things how explain
that from a geometric standpoint from a
pattern standpoint
so when you have a cycle of seven
there's a natural relationship where the
very first stage gets reflected in the
in the last stage
it's a it's a polarity relationship
everything's polarities right yep so
you're coming in and you're going out
they talk about that with dimensions a
lot where yes um like the the last
connects back to the first again that's
always the case okay all of us and that
have these recollections
of ourselves in ancient Egypt there's a
part of that that's being activated
right now now once we get into if we're
incarnating let's say in the sixth
post-atlantean Epoch we may be much more
focused on our ancient Persian
incarnations that's something that will
be called up inside of us there's a
great idea in what's called uh Vedic
astrology or jyotish in India which
which is uh that is there are certain
moments in time where your karmas will
ripen your karmas will be activated they
have a whole science of this in in India
of the Dasha periods it doesn't exist in
Western astrology at all but in the
Indian system you can get your dashes
read and you'll know what karma is going
to ripen at what moment of your life
certain experiences will happen then
same thing for us with our whole
Incarnation right now there's a certain
karma that's ripening from ancient Egypt
having to do with the abilities we gain
there remembering regaining those
abilities bringing them to bear in our
lives right now and bringing them to
prayer on the earth to help the Earth as
a whole right now everything is
intricately linked in a larger energetic
and spiritual system that modern science
has no concept of they only look at the
broken fragments that appear into
physical reality they look at the
collapse of the wave function where the
energetic waves have become a physical
object but they no longer understand the
larger Matrix that the waves are in
including at the higher Consciousness
levels before a wave that created the
physical world even came to into
existence
so understanding it from the classical
traditions of multiple planes of
existence all of which we participate in
we all have those within ourselves and
can experience all of them and ourselves
as a way to understand this and fractals
is a modern concept that really helps us
to understand how the same pattern at a
higher level of scale the same pattern
at a higher uh plane level manifest here
on this plane with the same pattern but
reduced in scale
I'll give you a particular example of an
idea of fractal reality from
two thousand years ago in Alexandria
Egypt in the early Christian centuries
when they were trying to understand what
is the nature of the Christ being in
early Christianity one of the great now
called a Church Father origin living in
Alexandria Egypt who had an incredible
book called on first principles and in
it he says the only way you can
understand what the Christ being is
we're not talking about the master Jesus
as a human being we're talking about
this larger cosmological being the solar
logos the Christ being says that way to
understand what this being is is that
the godhead is so vast the godhead is
everything it's so vast that you don't
get a
a a view of what that being is because
it's everything everywhere
he says what the Christ being is is a
macrocosmic being that has all the
qualities of the godhead but reduced in
scale to the macrocosmic level to where
we can actually perceive and interact
with this being
and in humanity also has the qualities
of the godhead but we're reduced to the
microcosmic level we're another level
reduced but it's the exact same fractal
pattern
and so we are microcosmic beings
with all the potentials of the godhead
Laden inside of us most of which have
been neutralized because people are so
screwed up today if you actually have
these higher Powers you'd create
incredible destruction all around you
but this idea that it's a fractal
movement from one level to another is an
ancient concept but today we can express
it in geometry and math and and get it
as a visual hit that's why I like
describing the idea about how the seven
time periods in a cycle work together by
giving the geometric form and that's why
they thought in ancient Judaism too
which is why they gave the image of the
menorah they didn't explain to the
average person what it meant that was
for the initiative to understand that's
the structure of time Cycles is there
something to be said about these
geometric structures even being in Egypt
they said that the you know the Ram or
any of the heads of the Lions of the of
the animals were were actually
geometrically activating something
within you when you looked at it is
there something happening by just
observing these structures these
patterns absolutely so for this let me
go to the work of biogeometry and my
friend and teacher in Egypt Dr Abraham
Karim and he's got some amazing work on
this within the biogeometry work so one
aspect of this is that he talks about
the way that in ancient Egypt they knew
an incredible secret and that secret was
the design code behind everything in
creation the design code that allows you
to crystallize physical forums into a
physical world from higher energetic
States
and that this became expressed through
things like the hieroglyphic text and
through some of the Expressions that
they had with design in ancient Egypt
and so there are certain energy
emanations coming from certain
hieroglyphs that if you test it with
energetic methods like vibrational
radiusthesia where you can detect subtle
energy waves coming off of things some
of these hieroglyphs have very powerful
energetic waves coming out from them
because of the shape information oh wow
like the
the ends into the wall
of it and create energetic structure it
creates an energetic effect so like you
were saying if you look at it doesn't
have an effect on you and the answer is
yes so they found ways to work with
shape information to be able to bring
forward all types of energy states so in
biogeometry to explain how we get the
effects we get with the work one of the
the concepts that we use developed by Dr
Kareem is that energy into shape creates
function
so energy is a proteus it could take any
form but how do we program the energy to
do a specific thing we have that energy
move in a specific pattern so the energy
movement pattern programs the energy to
take the action now that's why your
heart has a specific geometric shape
that's completely different from the
shape of the liver that's different from
the shape of the spleen Because the
actual shape is related to the function
oh
and so that's what biosignatures are you
mentioned earlier biosignatures from
just cycling back to that so so what
matters yeah it absolutely matters it's
like it's like Forum follows function
right so energy into shape creates
function that shape of the heart that
shape of the liver that shape of the
kidney
it actually then becomes a container
that has energy circulations inside of
it when that energy circulation of the
organ becomes impaired then the function
begins to degrade so what you're doing
when you provide a bio signature to a
person is you're creating a resonance
effect reminding the body of the correct
energy circulation and then restoring
the function to it now we don't make any
medical claims for it but that's the
idea so what is disease then well
disease that becomes another larger
topic there's actually a section on that
in the Advanced Training of biogeometry
but in dealing with it in a very short
frame one aspect of this is that we have
lost the correct energy circulation that
created the function of that part of the
body to begin with and at a deeper
metaphysical level it means that we've
lost a resonance between the
health-giving source at a higher level
of what comes into the body we're no
longer connected to it we're no longer
resonating with it we got to reconnect
with it it's like stop it's dormant and
so that's why this healing is very
important but again it's to become whole
again the energy circulations are back
we're reconnected to those larger
metaphysical levels I mean why is
cardiac disease one of the biggest
killers in the west today Broken Hearts
exactly everybody's got a broken heart
everybody's got an armored heart but
they hold rigid if you like this clip
and you want to hear the whole episode
click at the bottom of your screen